j moins 3 avant le second tour des
élections régionales les partis tentent
de mobiliser les troupes après un
premier tour marqué par un taux
d'abstention record plus de 66%
comment l'expliquer et doit-on
s'attendre à un chiffre aussi élevé
dimanche prochain les explications de
bastien que voulaient effectivement
l'abstention a atteint un niveau record
et tout porte à croire que cela sera la
même chose ce dimanche il y a des causes
d'ordre général et des raisons liées à
ces élections même premièrement
globalement la crise sanitaire fait que
sans doute les français n'avait pas
l'esprit aux élections il y aussi un
climat général de défiance vis-à-vis du
politique ou une certaine lassitude
domine chez les abstentionnistes qui ont
l'impression que leur vote n'a pas de
poids politique pour changer les
orientations liées à cela il y a
visiblement un problème d'incarnation
et puis il y à des facteurs qui font que
ces élections locales désintéresse et là
je reprendrai largement les arguments de
gérard françois dumont professeur de la
sorbonne qu'on avait contacté pour un
article
les lois de décentralisation comme la
loi notre ont créé des super structures
comme les régions qui n'ont aucune
réalité géographique ni historique
ces grands ensembles sont bien souvent
gérées par une bureaucratie qui
déconnecte l'élu du citoyen et le fait
est que les petits territoires et ceux
éloignés de la capitale régionale sont
généralement les perdants des réformes
de décentralisation or l'abstention se
retrouvent dans ces territoires
je dirais quelque peu oubliés des
politiques publiques
enfin ces régions et départements ont
des compétences complètement illisible
certaines se chevauchent entre les
communautés d'agglomération les
départements la région entre la
métropole du grand paris et la région
ile de france
il y a même une concurrence les élus
semblent eux-mêmes un peu perdu sur ce
qu'ils peuvent ou non faire donc
imaginer les électeurs